[Music]
you could be everything like be like be
the greatest actor actress singer be an
accountant be be everything you can be
like it you got one [ __ ] life don't
let people put you in a [ __ ] box
everybody's trying to put people a
[ __ ] box if you're [ __ ] talented
enough do everything if you're [ __ ]
Bo Jackson and Deion Sanders play both
for example I'm a good operator and I'm
a good personality so I do both some
people are good personalities but can't
run a business some can run a business
again some people can cook and sing some
people can't they do you like if you can
do comedy and [ __ ] music then go if
you're good enough you always get it the
rock was a wrestler now he's a [ __ ]
movie star well I meant was a [ __ ]
rapper and he was a [ __ ] movie star
Marky Mark was a [ __ ] rapper then he
was a movie star like if you're Ashton
Kutcher was an actor now he's a [ __ ]
baller businessman if you're good enough
nobody's gonna stop you
listen if you're talented enough if
you're [ __ ] Jamie Foxx go people said
I was [ __ ] the wine guy I couldn't do
it isn't as cool I was then I was an
investor I couldn't do advertised like
[ __ ] your boxes you're not putting me in
a [ __ ] box all of you you think you
know what I'm about right now [ __ ]
Tony cuz honestly I'm always [ __ ]
destroyed I can feel it my soul I'll let
you [ __ ] put me in a box and
everybody wants to be put in a box put
people's box I'm gonna start a [ __ ]
hot dog company you [ __ ] destroy the
world
you [ __ ] killed Nathan's maybe the
greatest
or am I just flip the [ __ ] script in
three years and just go [ __ ]
disappear
I'll find the Jets and [ __ ] making
videos I need a businessman and [ __ ]
just teach kids [ __ ] Pakistan I don't
[ __ ] know
but I've know one thing I'm definitely
not gonna listen to you
20 in [ __ ] box people trying to put
people in a box but you stopped see what
we do what they actually want it's
[ __ ] 2019 do your [ __ ] thing you do
everything I [ __ ] want to do I got 60
more years of [ __ ] destroying it
that's what plan to do and regardless of
what the articles written look what you
guys are saying behind my back or to my
face and the PM's are comments I'm
[ __ ] around but and anybody put me in
a box nobody not my family not the world
I'm gonna do me peace and quiet in my
own [ __ ] head that's all I want
don't you want happiness don't you
[ __ ] want to be happy [ __ ] don't let
anybody put you in a [ __ ] box live
[ __ ] boxes
[Music]